موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم مصدر الجيش
السوداني وبيانا قال فيه ان البلاد تمر
بمنعطف خطير بعد قيام قوات الدعم السريع
بحشد قواتها في العاصمه وبعض المدن ما يدق
ناقوس الخطر واضاف البيان ان تحركات قوات
الدعم السريع داخل العاصمه والولايات تمت
دون موافقه القوات المسلحه ومخالفه لمهام
ونظام عمل تلك القوات وقال البيان ان
استمرار تحركات الدعم السريع سيؤدي الى
مزيد من الانقسامات والتوترات التي تقود
الانفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد وفق تعبير
البيان
وكان مصدر عسكري سوداني قد قال ان قوات
الدعم السريع حركت قوات ضخمه في مدينه
مراووي دون اخطار الجيش وتم استدعاء قوات
من مناطق اخرى لمواجهه الموقف وقال المصدر
ان القوات المسلحه طالبت قوات الدعم
السريع بالانسحاب بمنطقه تمركوزها الجديد
في مروي في غضون 24 ساعه وان لم تفعل
فسيتم اجبارها على ذلك وقد اظهرت لقطات
وصول تعزيزات من قوات الجيش السوداني ليلى
الاربعاء الى مروي
وكان مصدر مطلع في حكومه الولايه الشماليه
في السودان قال ان حكومه الولايه فوجئت
بانتشار نحو 100 سياره نقل عسكريه تابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع بالقرب من مطار مروي
دون اي تنسيق مسبق مع سلطات الولايه
في المقابل قال مكتب الناطق الرسمي باسم
قوات الدعم السريع ان بعض وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تناقلت ما سماها مزاعم بان قوات
الدعم السريع قامت باعمال حربيه تجاه مطار
مروي واوضح المكتب في بيان ان قوات الدعم
السريع قوات قوميه تعمل في اطار القانون
بتنسيق وتناغم تام مع قياده القوات
المسلحه
واضافت ان وجودها بالولايه الشماليه وفي
مدينه مرويه ضمن وجودها في بقيه الولايات
في اطار تاديه مهامها وواجباتها التي تمتد
حتى الصحراء
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن وزير الدفاع
الياباني قوله وناكوريا الشماليه اطلقت
صاروخا باليسيا قد يكون من النوع العادي
للقارات واضاف ان صاروخ لم يسقط داخل
الاراضي اليابانيه وانما في مياه المحيط
وقد حذرت السلطات اليابانيه من سقوط
الصاروخ على منطقه هوكايدو وطالبه سكان
المنطقه بالاحتماء في الملاجئ بينما اطلقت
صفارات الانذار من جهه ادان الجيش الكوري
الجنوبي اطلاق الصواريخ الباليستيه
واعتبرها انتهاكا لقرارات مجلس الامن
قالت وكاله رويتر زينا الصين تخطط لفرض
منطقه حظر طيران شمال تايوان بين السادس
عشر والثامن عشر من شهر ابريل الجاري من
جانبه قال الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده ستدافع
عن سيادتها الاقليميه وحقوقها البحريه
هذا وقال نائب رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
للاستخبارات التايوانيه ان منطقه حظر
الطيران التي اعلنتها الصين تقع داخل
منطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لودوست واشنطن
شاهدت زياده مقلقه في السلوك الخطير ببحر
جنوب الصين واضاف ان الولايات المتحده ما
زالت متمسكه بالتزاماتها تجاه تحالفها مع
الفلبين وفق معاهده الدفاع المتبادل
من جهه قال مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز انه من
الضروري ان تاخذ الولايات المتحده رغبه
الصين في السيطره على تايوان بجديه بالغه
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ناموسكو
ليس لديها اي موقف بشان مساله تسريب وثائق
البنتاجون السريه لكنها لا تستبعد ان يتم
استخدام معلومات كاذبه بهدف تضليل روسيا
وفق تعبيره
بجانبه قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي
نواشنطن تحاول ان تشرح لحلفائها ما حدث
بشان المعلومات الاستخباراتيه المسربه
الخاصه بالحرب في اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان
التحقيقات لم تظهر الكثير بعد
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]